he certainly subscribes to Scientology
and you know whether you're going to
call it a religion or a cult it's
clearly a you know been been questioned
in and outside of Hollywood I think you
know it's a very unfortunate turn of
events for him you know he had so much
star power you know could could open
movies to millions and millions of
dollars and and whether that's on the
wane or you know he's never going to
recapture that you know is still up for
debate I don't think we've seen enough
yet but i but i do think you know his
antics are out of control you know his
relationship with katie holmes and the
you know sort of ongoing suspicions
about their daughter to the you know
attacks on you know scientology from you
know various biographers you know it
doesn't seem like the best place to be
for him in his career right now he
really you know came to be as this sort
of Hollywood hunk and really was the
epitome of a leading man in Hollywood
and now he's a punchline and that's a
that's a very quick turn of events that
happened there very quickly the church
has made no secret of the fact that they
aim to ingrain themselves in Hollywood
and celebrity culture they understand
that these people can sort of be
liaisons for their belief system and and
use that to export it when you have
people who are so closely watched by
America in the rest of the world whether
they're drinking diet pepsi or you know
reading a new book or happen to be a
Scientologist that will impact some
people you can't ride the subway here in
New York without being approached to
have you know a stress test by a group
of Scientologists so you know I think
it's it's no secret again that the
church has tried to use celebrity for
its own purposes as far as you know
celebrities themselves I think one of
the most entertaining rumors or
suggestions is that the you note
Scientology has gone after closeted
homosexuals in the industry and offered
them Scientology as a means to you know
cure themselves of their gay ways and I
think the rumors are fueled by the fact
that there's so much speculation around
Tom Cruise John Travolta even Will Smith
about their sexuality so I think that's
one of the more amusing rumors how much
weight it you know how much weight it
carries in accuracy you know who knows I
think it's a safe haven and I think
that's what any you know any organ I you
know organization that calls itself
religion whether we're talking
Christianity Judaism Islam you know I
think what what religion offers is that
safe haven in that sense of community
you know if we're going to call this an
alternative religion so be it but I
think at the core it's offering its
members who happen to be very
high-profile people the same sorts of
things that most other religions would
promise you know its attendees
you